Today, network file systems are an
important component of any computing environment, be
it a corporate setting or university setting.
There are companies that have sprung up
such as NetApp solely to pedal scalable NFS products. In this lesson, going
beyond NFS we learned a lot of
concepts pertaining to the design and implementation
of distributed file systems, in particular
how to make the implementation scalable
by removing centralization and utilizing memory
that's available in the nodes of a
local area network intelligently. Such techniques
for identifying and removing bottlenecks are the
reusable nuggets that we can take and apply to the design and implementation
of other distributed subsystems in additions to file systems themselves.
Overall, in the set of papers that we studied in
this lesson module spanning, GSM, DSM and DFS,
we discussed the design and implementation of subsystems that found creative
ways to fully utilize memory that's available in the nodes
of a local area network.